[Music]
chuck them back
in your face yes you are in your face
[Laughter]
okay i got nothing for this week
anything bugging you all right well good
i'm glad i'm i'm sure you have something
but
here's the deal
it's impossible for you to have nothing
but that's true that is true but i you
know i just want to break right
from having to get this stuff so here's
the thing an inordinate
and an inordinate number of people
online
want to know about ufos which to me
i'm like how does a scientist talk about
ufos because just to be clear could you
could you quantify
inordinate yeah well
isn't there an inordinate number of
people online that
believe anything uh you know what if you
we are talking the internet so
yes you're right yeah it doesn't make a
difference cause they find each other
yes they do they create
communities they get together and they
breed and as a result
the world suffers so
that's it's unfortunate but that's what
happens
but you're absolutely right so uh that's
a perfect
example of what i'm talking about you
see the same thing happen with
conspiracy theories you see the same
thing happening
with you know uh vaxxers or i should say
anti-vaxxers
and with the ufos
the thing is no matter what
they have already made up their mind we
have been visited
there is life outside of our
solar system um
aliens are among us uh
crop circles all this stuff and my thing
is like
if it weren't from movies none of this
crap
would exist all of this crap comes out
of movies it's hollywood
hollywood has fueled our obsession
with ufos and alien life and i really
believe that
but you being a scientist i'm interested
what do you guys in your community
looking out into space for your entire
life
how do you view ufos
first of all i love me some aliens
nobody doesn't love the aliens okay
right that would be
a discovery of of all of civilization
if aliens showed up and we sat down and
had tea
with them actually if they showed up and
we did anything with them
right whether or not we served tea so
most likely they would serve tea while
they eat
us see see the movies
i'm telling you the movies it's all
movies so let me offer
just a couple of uh perspectives just so
we can
let me orbit it first with perspectives
and then i'll land in the middle
by the end okay so first of all notice
how frequently aliens
are hostile to us as portrayed
in movies uh and that goes back to
the twilight zone and before of course
one of the more famous episodes they had
aliens in many episodes by the way
but this is back in the 1960s late 50s
that
uh an episode called to serve man where
aliens came and they
helped us grow crops and they gave us
secrets to our energy needs and they
there was peace all over the earth and
they invited us to go back and visit
them
and uh they accidentally left behind a
book called to serve man
within their own sort of hieroglyphic
kind of text
and so they got all the best
cryptographers looking at it
and after everyone has already decided
yeah let's go visit their planet because
they're obviously superior to us
and we're all very well fed because the
crops are
bounty all over the earth and then
they find out that to serve man it is a
cookbook that's awesome
it's a cookbook that's so great
now it is rumored i've not studied this
but i've
i've read studies that to a child
it is far worse to be eaten
than to just die
so of all the ways to die they're not
even afraid of other ways to die
but the idea of being eaten is
particularly horrifying
i think to anybody that's what well okay
especially children but and that's why
the fairy tales
are always involved brothers the witch
eats you
the ogre eats you the truth they don't
just stab you
right right they don't shoot you they
don't throw you off a cliff
they each and this is terrifying and i
think this is why
we as children um deeply respect t-rex
ask any kid who their favorite animal is
it's t-rex because
you respect anything that can eat you
right and then you bring them over to
astrophysics and say what's your
favorite object in astrophysics
it's black holes because they can each
okay okay
all right so here's the thing so the
this evil alien concept
i it feels like
we are basing this on
actual evidence of how we
treat each other rather than on
any notion of how
aliens would actually treat us so
so in other words we we are projecting
onto aliens what we already know
we do to each other because in the
history of
civilization there i even use that word
in these examples
you have a highly technologically able
culture descends upon a less
technologically able
culture particularly in the era of
colonization of the world
and it never boded well for the culture
that had less technology
whoever whoever was getting visited
visited
and we do this to our own species
so i think our fear of aliens
derives not from knowledge of how they
would behave but from knowledge of how
we would behave not with each other and
probably how we would treat
other aliens as well so so i think
that's what's going on there that's my
first point
second all the aliens portray nearly all
the aliens portrayed they're
they're they walk they talk they have
two arms legs nose eyes mouth
head and look at e.t look at the aliens
in close encounters of the third kind
look at um even in the movie series
alien an alien followed by aliens and
that right
that alienated while it didn't
specifically have legs
it it was it was vertebrate right it had
like
a face a face is a very vertebrate thing
to have yeah all right if you're not a
vertebrate in this world
you don't have much of a face however
having two mouths
a mouth within a mouth that was not a
bad touch
well that's the that's the getting eaten
part that's a little more terrifying
okay
so so uh think about amoebas don't
have mouths trees don't have mouths
uh we just keep going down the list and
like i said the
the traditional face that we think of it
tends to be a vertebrate phenomenon
and so we are then making aliens
vertebrates
okay right uh the movie arrival that was
not a vertebrate that was a
septipod yeah so that was so i like it
when they try to go a little
uh they step outside of the comfort box
of how we think aliens should be
and it means yeah an actor's not getting
a payday that day
because they're not donning an alien
costume in order to do this
um in the movie a rival which i
recommend you know it has some
it has some strong points in it it's
cool movie
yeah the the aliens come and they have
these pods
positioned all around the world by the
way the hubris of us to imagine that
aliens
would care about us or be curious
about us that's hubris it's like we're
so interesting that another species that
can travel across the galaxy
is going to study our behavior when
you're walking down the sidewalk
and you see a worm do you pause and say
gee i wonder what that worm is thinking
gee let me let me let me figure out how
this works
no no you put it on a hook and you go
get dinner
so so just to believe that we are so
interesting
that something as advanced as a
civilization with flying saucers
to cross the galaxy would sit there and
want to analyze us
so so that's hubris okay
uh so there's that but also
consider uh how many
photographs are taken every day
everybody's got a smartphone right
almost everybody high resolution
uh and if you're not taking a photo
you're taking a video
and so you if there's something unusual
and interesting you're taking a video of
that
we have video of stuff you never got
videos of before like
cops beating up black folk okay i grew
up
that's happened all the time nobody had
video to have video live
cop's word against the black person's
word we now have video of everything
that was once rare and it still makes no
difference
editorializing i'm sorry during the
explainer video i'm just stating
i'm just staying in the situation so
you'd think
an alien encounter would be rare but
you've got a smartphone and you can
stream it in the old days when people
said did you take pictures of the alien
that abducted you
yeah but they stole the film or i got
the film
home and the whole roll was blank
because the alien zapped it or whatever
so so it's a recording device but a
streaming device is not a recording
device
so you can live stream whatever is
happening all right
so so you would expect given how many
reports of abductions there were right
of decades past that somebody would have
that on
you know that be posted by now and it
hasn't been
so this leads me to think strongly
that people's imaginations got the
better side
of their life experience when they came
back to
report on having been abducted okay
so there's that so so so that's aliens
that's just
aliens but how about ufos so you see
something flying and it's
something you don't know what it is and
let me just say i was gonna tweet this
too maybe i should
i was going to say the fact
that you don't know what it is
is not evidence that you know what it is
okay that's actually that's pretty
profound because
that's exactly what people do so there's
lights in the sky
moving in a peculiar way and you can't
explain it it's
unidentified and it's flying and it's an
object so it's a ufo it must be alien
and then p
so i don't know what it is therefore it
must be
a b c d elemental p alien and i'm
thinking
you just admitted you don't know what it
is what it is that's kind of where that
stops
we're done here okay it's time to get
more and better data okay so now
in science do you know why science
exists
because the human sensory system sucks
that's why science exists makes sense
all right we can see bands of light
that your retina cannot we can see
things dimmer
than the sensitivity of your cones can
pick up
the cones in your in your eye we can uh
the
rods and cones right for detecting color
and for
but and and brightness we um
those fail when you're trying to see
things
that are dim and
outside of the range of what we call
visible light and this is this is
stuff we didn't even know existed until
scientists discovered it
we discovered x-rays and ultraviolet and
gamma rays and radio waves
and and microwaves that's all light okay
we have telescopes
honed into those windows to the universe
and we drink in
these phenomena and then convert them to
ways that our senses can then detect
them we make a photo we have chart
recorders this sort of thing
point is the advance of science and
civilization
with it came about
primarily because we invented machines
to replace our sensory system
because it fails so badly and
look why do we have whole books on what
do you call them
optical illusions right right those are
fun nobody doesn't love and opt a good
optical illusion
and and what is an optical illusion it's
oh there's a line
and it's it's simple right it's simple
line drawing on a white page
oh is that line bigger than the other
one i don't know or they're the same
size oh my gosh
look how easy it is to fool you
and this is just a simple line drawing
now i'm going to have something
complicated in in
in twilight with in a in a sky
with you've never seen but and and now
you're i'm expecting you to give me an
accurate account of what just happened
no so in science eyewitness testimony
is the lowest form of evidence
there is in fact is so low we don't even
we basically don't accept it wow so when
you see people say
this was a navy pilot who's trained and
he's a credible witness for what he saw
uh you're saying species you're saying
that guy is just as much a dumbass as
anybody standing on the ground
that navy pilot or not being a human
being
he's susceptible to the same perception
bias that anybody else perception bites
and that's not purposeful you know right
they're not trying to
it's just the consequence of
the human being trying to make sense of
their world and when things don't make
sense
we have the urge to make it make sense
so that we can think about it in some
way that's consistent with our life
experience
so i've had people say uh
oh i saw this this bright light in the
sky it was huge
so no they meant it was just bright
because the vocabulary is
i saw this light and it was a few inches
above marty's deli
what do you mean a few inches was it an
angle it was in the sky you know
so even our capacity to retell things is
compromised
because we're human all right so all i'm
asking for
is among the six billion images and
videos
uplifted to the internet every day that
are high resolution
uh it'd be nice if a few of them had an
alien getting out of their spacecraft or
you
going up to greet the give me some
footage of that some high-res videos
but you don't have that what you have
is lately fuzzy
navy video monochromatic
and so you're telling me that the aliens
are only revealing themselves to the
navy
well that's not a bad place to start
they do have the best uniforms
plus if the aliens are everywhere but do
you know how many planes when we're
in full flying mode you know how many
planes are crisscrossing this planet
every minute all right if we were if
there were aliens all over the place
this would be like a major
hazard for airplanes okay and we'd be
seeing them
all the time all right so we take this
one
case out of tens or hundreds of
thousands
and it's a weird thing and nobody can
explain it and all of a sudden everybody
can explain it so that's the i don't
know what it is
therefore i know what it is so by the
way
we as scientists we'd love to meet the
aliens i have no
problems with this we just need better
evidence than your credible witness
i just need better evidence than your
fuzzy video but anyhow i'm ready for
them bring them on
and just it just seems to me if we'd be
visited more than the navy
would notice it that's all i'm saying
and you think the government is
keeping secrets first you think the
government is
competent enough to keep such a if we
were stockpiling
you don't think a cell phone image is
going to get out of area 51.
something will get out you know really
really
do you really think the government is
that competent
really anyone whose work for the
government knows differently
and of course the government tries to
keep secrets of course they
try but anything as juicy
as an alien plus if aliens are on their
way do you know how many telescopes we
have pointing up to the night sky
do you realize how that's how much the
night guy's being monitored by people
other than human beings also do you
realize
we have cameras pointing downward you
know google earth
are down with pointing cameras okay all
right if aliens are landing and taking
off
we would have footage so instead of
asking how come scientists
don't agree that what you can't identify
is alien try to think differently about
it
and ask if they were aliens visiting
earth
what would that be like somebody would
see it
somebody would have photographed it
would it ended up in google earth it
would show up in many many many many
many many more airplanes given how many
airplanes
fly around the earth every single hour
or
just think that through the absence of
that level of supportive evidence for me
is very strong against
the alien interpretation of something
you can't identify in the night sky
so and by by the way keep keep get bring
a net
grab one you'll be rich and famous
overnight more power to you i'm not
going to get in your way
but your what you present as what you
think is evidence
is insufficient in our scientific court
of law
this has been a star talk explainer neil
degrasse tyson
signing off by bidding you to keep
looking up
[Music]